-I want to ask about something.
Right around Christmas,
we do this thing called
"Day Drinking" on the show.
And I was doing it with Lizzo,
and your name came up.
-I saw it.
-Yeah.
And again, it must have been
very exciting,
because Lizzo, let me tell you,
one of the most charming
human beings.
I don't know if you've been
lucky enough to meet her.
-I've never met her.
I watched --
I mean, I watched.
It was on the show.
And when I heard Lizzo
say my name, I was like...
I got all excited.
By the way, it's a weird thing
when you're not expecting
to hear that and you hear it.
And that segment was hilarious,
by the way.
That whole -- Every time
you do it, it's so funny.
-She really did
sort of raise the bar.
I keep telling people
she's so deeply funny.
Even while, like, inebriated,
she, like, talks like
a comedy writer.
-So funny, so charming.
Yeah, it was great.
-She also -- I've told this a
few times, but the great thing,
to bring it back to my dad,
you know,
one of her catchphrases
is "Bye, bitch."
-Right.
-And we left a message --
we left a voicemail for my dad,
and she said --
she ended it by saying,
"Bye, bitch."
-Yeah.
-Then independent of me,
she got my dad's information
and sent him flowers
with a note that said,
"I'm sorry
I called you a bitch."
[ Laughter ]
And my brother and I
call him a bitch all the time.
We've never apologized.
-You owe him a lot of flowers.
-Yeah, we owe him
a lot of flowers.
"You made us root for
the Steelers, you bitch."
[ Laughter ]
So, anyway, but the reason
your name came up
is one of our writers walked
out, and he was wearing a mask,
and Lizzo -- and again,
she'd had a few drinks.
She thought it was Paul Rudd.
She thought it was you.
So the writer's here today,
but first I want to show
the first half of the clip,
and then we're gonna bring out
the writer, Seth Reiss.
So here's Lizzo noticing
our writer the first time.
-Ohh, I'm calm now.
-Alright, let's bring him over.
-Paul [bleep] Rudd!
Paul Rudd!
-Hey, Lizzo,
I know the real reason
you're breaking up with me
is that you met famous
Hollywood actor Paul Rudd,
who's now gonna
take his mask off,
and I want you to react to it
in real time.
-[Bleep]
-Alright, so now we're gonna
bring out the writer.
And we're gonna let you guys
decide, was Lizzo crazy?
[ Laughter, cheering ]
Alright, you know what?
Not -- Not --
Not as bad as I thought.
I owe an apology to Lizzo.
But now this is
the really exciting part, guys.
'Cause again, I think
you're agreeing with Lizzo.
This is not too far afield,
until you see the rest
of the face.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of other stuff can happen.
-This better not be --
This better --
Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't even look.
-I need a tissue.
I need a tissue, please.
No, here's the thing.
You don't look anything
like [bleep] Paul Rudd.
[ Laughter ]
-There we go.
Let's see both faces.
There we go.
Paul and Seth Reiss,
brothers from another mother.
-Thank you so much.
-It's like looking in a mirror.
-It's like looking in a mirror!
-Thank you so much.
-And look at these two.
Two snowflakes can be alike.
We'll be right back with more
from Paul Rudd, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]